acclaimed actor Brian Cranston will stop
gracing our screens in a few years but
it's for the nicest possible reason I
can't simply quit in an interview with a
British GQ promoting his latest film
asteroid City Cranston revealed that
he's gonna take a step back from magding
in 2026 so that he can devote more time
to his wife of 34 years Robin dearden
apparently has a specific plan in mind
he's going to shutter his production
company as a move to a foreign country
possibly France for as long as he can
with deer Den the actor will also turn
70 that year he told GQ I want to change
the Paradigm once again for the last 24
years Robin has led her life holding
onto my tail she's been the plus one
she's been the wife of a celebrity she's
had to Pivot and adjust her life based
on mine she has tremendous benefit from
it but we're uneven I want to level that
out she deserves it Cranston told the
magazine he wants to enjoy a different
lifestyle where he can explore new
places Cozier by the fireplace and sip
wine with new friends he added that he
won't be looking for any new projects or
taking any calls related to work during
his hiatus
I'm done it's not entirely unexpected
that Cranston wants to take a break from
acting though he's definitely successful
and has built an incredible career for
himself he's also been working hard for
decades after making the leap from
sitcoms to prestige dramas with Breaking
Bad cranston's name entered the best
living actor conversation in a big way
and along the way he's rugged up Emmy
wins and Oscar nominations now he's
working with celebrated director Wes
Anderson alongside the rest of the stars
that had cast on asteroid City and an
anecdote shared by his co-stars hope
Davis and Jason Schwartzman illustrates
what Cranston is like behind the scenes
apparently when filming rap to Cranston
threw a huge party for everyone and
personally ensure that it would be a
huge success Davis told GQ it's a huge
Ensemble movie and yet he threw this
beautiful party for everyone at the end
because he's a gentleman and he likes to
make a good time schwarzmann pointed out
that in addition to hosting Hanson made
Margaritas for everybody all night he
made every single drink for everyone
that night he wasn't at the party he
worked the party sounds like dear Dem
will have a pretty great life with the
Cranston abroad and as for his fans we
still have a few years left to enjoy his
performances speaking of fans Constance
announcement is quite understandably
made waves among the fandom with the
many admirers of his work taking to
social media in order to voice her
opinions about the news mom Reddit user
posted I don't know why I thought he was
still in his 50s but damn it will be sad
to see him step away from the big screen
another Reddit user dealt with the last
Sprite bringing in the jokes posting
okay he needs to be certified as a
National Monument so he is available at
least annually but oh well good on him
but what a lust to acting what is
understandable that some fans are
disappointed to see an acting Titan of
cranston's caliber step away people also
Express support for the actor's plans
writer John Winkler tweeted if Brian
Cranston wants to retire and move to
France in a few years he's earned it
meanwhile some fans suspect that
cranston's absence will be much briefer
than reports syndicate with one
speculating that he'll return to the big
screen as soon as 2027. all in all the
fans seem to understand the cranston's
desire to step away in a controlled
fashion but then nevertheless sad to see
him go one fun on Reddit summed it up
like this it's a loss for us because
he's great but it's well deserved and he
should take time to enjoy life for the
person he loves
foreign